we're going to begin this hour though
with the late actor and cultural icon
that would be Sidney Poitier
but you think of yourself as a colored
man
I think of myself
as a man
oh we all remember that line that's Mr
portier in the classic film Guess Who's
Coming to Dinner Fortier was an
international star appearing in dozens
of movies over his incredible career he
made history history in so many ways he
was the first black man to win the
Academy Award for best actor Oprah as in
Winfrey is honoring his legacy with a
new documentary that she produced it's
called simply Sydney it premiered
earlier this month at the Toronto Film
Festival it was a huge hit we spoke with
Oprah the film's director that's
Reginald hudlin and three of Sidney
Poitier's daughters about the man on and
off the screen
that uh Quincy Jones the world I knew
was quite simple the stories shared in
Sydney are told by the one person who
could tell them best Sidney Poitier I
said I am going to become an actor it's
his story in his words Pamela portier is
one of his six daughters because no one
can tell you who Sidney Poitier is
except Sidney Poitier I never thought
about what I look like I didn't know
what a mirror was I love it the way he
goes I didn't know what a mirror was
Oprah produced a Sydney documentary and
she recorded the interview featured
throughout the film it was done for her
master class TV series back in 2012. and
that interview ended up lasting two days
we have over eight hours of conversation
with him that becomes the spine of this
movie and the reason why it's the spine
in the movie is because he had the
foresight then I didn't like it one bit
I called them to flee with him he said
you can only air this one time he says I
have told my story in a way that my
family has not heard me speak before and
this is all they will have of me when
I'm gone Poitier's family gave Oprah
permission to use the interview one more
time we spoke with three of the late
actor's daughters
Pamela Anika and Sydney this was the
first time they had all gathered
together since their father's death the
extraordinary man that the world knows
my dad to be is the extraordinary man
that he is in The Quiet Moments when
he's at home when you all were growing
up what did you think your father did
well we didn't know
one time we thought he was a saxophone
player
because we went to Paris and he was in
this basement with Louis Armstrong
and Paul Newman and he was playing the
sacks yeah okay he's a musician okay
okay it wasn't until we were allowed to
see Lilies of the Field
and so when you saw him and Lily's the
field Pamela what did you think I
thought he was a contractor
right I thought that's what he builds
the churches he builds churches all
right yes I mean you know I mean I knew
it was a movie but still I didn't know
like he was an actor because as a kid
you would think oh my daddy does that
that's what he does and they're going to
do a movie about him doing that it must
be a dog or good contractor they made a
movie about it Reginald hudlin directed
the documentary it's a it's a movie
about a movie star
I have a movie star telling the story we
asked him about this impactful scene in
cinematic history Poitier insisted this
moment be in the script
foreign
the powerful thing about the moment is
that he is slapped and before we can
respond to the fact that Sydney protea
just got slapped we are all collectively
offended his slap boom happens right
that fast and whatever you thought was
going to happen that is not what you
thought and in that moment your mental
change are broken I know like that can
happen it can happen in a movie that can
happen in real life what in the
documentary Spike Lee and Quincy Jones
weigh in on that moment too blackballs
went crazy because they never seen that
before
what bam he was something else man in
the same year To Sir with Love yeah In
the Heat of the Night Guess Who's Coming
to Dinner he is changing the culture on
a planetary level yeah but there was a
part portier refused to play there was a
role as a janitor which he didn't mind
being the janitor but in the in the
characterization of the janitor the
janitor's daughter is murdered and
thrown on the lawn and he is not given
any lines of recourse to respond to that
and he said he could never play that
role which was going to pay him 750 750
a week at the time that was a lot of
money at the time when he was making 75
a week as a dishwasher and he turned
down the roll for 750 a week because his
father Reginald portier would never have
allowed a daughter of his to be thrown
on the lawn and not have any recourse
because of his father Oprah first met
Sidney Poitier at her 42nd birthday
party thrown by Quincy Jones that night
one of the reasons we had such a
powerful connection because at the time
I was getting criticized by so many
black people for not doing for not being
black enough for not doing enough black
shows and why are you hugging white
people on your show and why more than
you and I was uh I was and so I had that
conversation with him that first night
and he said my dear it's always a
challenge when you're carrying other
people's dreams
you're carrying other people's dreams
and so that bonded our connection and so
we talked about that and you know just
life born two months premature in 1927
Sydney portier was not expected to
survive
his journey is so Written in the Stars
it's so one of those stories that you
almost can't believe every step of the
way there were Angels just all around
him portier died in January he was 94
years old it really hasn't been a full
year and I remember when I lost my
parents that first year for me was sort
of a whirlwind because you have to go
through the first birthdays his birthday
your birthday Christmas Thanksgiving
Father's Day so as we sit here today I'm
wondering how you're healing how you're
dealing
um I have my good days and I have my not
so good days
um but I am allowing myself to feel what
I'm feeling
like Pam it's been a roller coaster it's
up and down
um he was such an anchor
for us not just as a family but for the
world you know he anchored this goodness
and this presence and this safety and
that's gone when Gail's mother died uh
I remember I was having
someone for dinner at my house and she
didn't want to interrupt the dinner and
so she waited until the dinner was done
and she called and she said I the first
thing she said was I lost my anchor
Today I was 40 you know I'm a grown-up
but it's still for me it was still my
mom
we try day to day to find ways to
connect with him
and um
you know I mean just to lighten it up a
little bit he and I both like to work in
bed he loves to like he wrote all his
books in bed and he loved to work in bed
and so soon after he passed I started
going and sitting in his bed and working
oh in his bed in his bed yeah this for
me and working on this project with
Reginald and our team
was an act of love
and after he passed it became my own
memorial offering to him
and nothing has made me more proud than
to know that people will be able to see
him through the eyes that we all have
seen him yeah and will come to know the
man he was because I will tell you of
all the people I've known in my life
set with in my life interviewed in my
life read about in my life there is no
human being more extraordinary and no
human being that I love more than Sydney
Poitier
yeah there was a lot of emotion in the
room that day that word you can see it
on the tape Oprah looks at me when she
says anchoring and I lost my anchor
because that word is so triggering and I
hadn't thought of it in years but just
the way she said it it brought back all
sorts of memories from me but Oprah and
Sydney had a very close relationship she
talked to him every single Sunday wow
sometimes for an hour sometimes 15
minutes sometimes two hours about
everything so they had a deep deep deep
connection and the thing that always
struck us about Sidney Poitier he was a
man of such Integrity Integrity back
when he did at the time when he was
offered that role his second daughter
was about to be born he had six
daughters his second daughter was about
to be born and he still turned it down
it was great sitting with his six
daughters he's been married twice and
he's got six girls uh five are still
living and I'm the oldest of four girls
and I asked him do you think your dad
wanted a son he said no he always said
he didn't but Sydney said I'm named
Sydney yeah because they were expecting
what they were hoping for what I'm still
named Sydney so there's deep love and
this was the first time guys that the
daughters had gotten together since her
father died and the first time they'd
seen the documentary together and that
was at a film festival it was at the
Toronto Film Festival it got a standing
ovation very very widely and positively
the word integrity stands out because we
say that life is about compromise but
for Sydney it wasn't he he did not waver
on what he stood on I can't wait to see
the documentary but God to be honest I'm
going to go home and watch that piece
again that was powerful yeah yeah I
believe when you see the dog Denzel's in
it Halle Berry is in it Barbra
Streisand's in it Lenny Kravitz it goes
on and on Sydney premieres by the way in
theaters and on Apple TV plus when this
Friday you can all take a look